la hermana paola salió expulsada por el
gobierno nicaragüense junto a sus 17
compañeras de la asociación misioneras
de la caridad ahora desde costa rica
hacen su labor social pero lamenta no
poder seguir ayudando a los más
desprotegidos en nicaragua dolor con
pena pero sabiendo pues que desde la fe
ve viendo que es la voluntad de dios lo
entendemos porque pero la voluntad de
dios siempre está ahí verdad las
autoridades en nicaragua anularon a más
de mil ongs de toda índole
inclusive universidades como la paulo
freire su rector considera que es una
represalia por su respaldo a
universitarios que protagonizaron
masivas protestas contra el gobierno
hace cuatro años desde san jose imparte
clases a nicaragüenses refugiados
tenemos
a contribuir
a que la generación de jóvenes que fue
pulsada el país se eduque el cierre de
organizaciones empezó en 2018 elvira
cuadra trabajaba en ese entonces para
dos centros de investigación social y
académica que fueron obligados a cerrar
sus puertas decidió fundar uno nuevo en
costa rica la investigadora considera
que la abolición de la sociedad civil es
un objetivo del presidente daniel ortega
mientras exista sociedad civil mientras
existan organizaciones sociales en
nicaragua
eso constituye un factor
que
contravienen su proyecto de estado
policial y de continuidad en el poder
la asamblea nicaragüense controlada por
el oficialismo justifica que las
organizaciones han incumplido las leyes
naciones unidas- rechaza el actuar del
gobierno de ortega y ha dicho que sin
espacio cívico no hay democracia